uh we have um the resurgence of the matt
gates story
now many of you wrote to me uh two weeks
ago
last week maybe even three weeks ago
saying
david what on earth happened to that
matt gates investigation we learned
that congr republican congressman from
florida matt gates has been
under investigation possibly for child
sex trafficking
he may have paid underage girls for sex
he may have actually paid to uh
transit them from one state to another
there's all this stuff blowing up uh
with matt gates
but then the story just kind of
disappeared and my view two weeks ago my
view last week was it's going to come
back there have been distractions
because of other things that have been
going on
the joe biden address to a joint session
of congress etc etc
all of these other things the story is
now coming back and we are now learning
that federal investigators
as reported by the week are pushing for
the cooperation
of two key witnesses in investigating
matthew gates including an ex-girlfriend
of matt gates when the investigators
talk to the ex-girlfriend
it's rarely good if the ex-girlfriend
cooperates
it's very very bad for matt gates and
investigators are looking for
cooperation from an ex-girlfriend
who is actually an intern on capitol
hill
uh i don't think many of us would be
shocked by that and
they are also looking for formal
cooperation
from that joel greenberg he's the former
county tax collector in florida
who we now have reason to believe
because of a letter he wrote
that greenberg himself introduced matt
gates to underage
girls um this is all potentially
disastrous for matt gates the
investigation
in part is over whether gates had sex
with a 17 year old girl
and violated federal sex trafficking
laws
he's denied wrongdoing the denials are
essentially meaningless at this point
and the former girlfriend that
investigators are seeking cooperation
from
reportedly joined gates in 2018
on a trip to the bahamas which has
become a big focus of the investigation
she was quote involved in some financial
transactions that the fbi has obtained
and is quote believed to have knowledge
of drug use
and arrangements with women this is
potentially
very bad for matt gates we expected
that as things settled back down in the
u.s we would get back to the gates story
and indeed the news is starting to flow
on that and
consider the insanity to go back to our
story about
the cancellation of republican
congresswoman liz cheney
who's been voted out of her
leadership role because she said hey
guys
trump lost essentially um look at how
the republican party
has been almost silent on the gates
fiasco
but are overly zealous to punish liz
cheney merely for saying
yeah biden one consider that incredible
hypocrisy and
it's not just that they claim to be
against cancel culture
but they regularly try to cancel people
they also regularly
regularly are going after the wrong
people and the gates cheney thing
is exhibit a and um
whether matt gates will be charged we
still don't know there's a lot of
unknowns here
but it is not looking particularly good